MGM and Amazon might just go alone with
Stargate and that opens up a very
interesting possibility that Stargate
could go home
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so for a few weeks now I've been telling
you that Amazon are hoping to strike a
deal with somebody like Warner Brothers
or Sony and to be honest it looked
increasingly likely that it was going to
be Warner Brothers that was going to be
the partner for any new Stargate
franchise particularly the movies
the Amazon because they don't really own
much Studio space I think they have like
three Studios of Culver City or
something
that they were looking for a partner
that they could actually create the
Stargate movies far quicker and far
easier than they can on their own now
Amazon have always had a long-term
ambition to become a big studio in their
own right but you know you can't run
before you can walk and Warner Brothers
have the studio space they need they
also have a very successful and very
experienced animation team so they could
deliver lots of different projects very
rapidly
but there has been a little bit of a
problem and perhaps they're looking to
go a different way now so what is the
issue well for one they have had
conversations with Sony about
potentially being a creative partner for
Stargate Robocop and a couple of other
things if they go into a deal like that
apparently they want to control elements
of the IP they want to actually own
parts of the project that they then
actually produce
Amazon don't like that idea
so they're happy to work with Sony when
it's sort of an original project or
something that they're already involved
in so doing the boys with Sony is
absolutely fine but doing something that
actually Amazon already owns say
Stargate not so much
so Warner Brothers Well Warner Brothers
are looking apparently for a long-term
deal they want something that's going to
be like about 15 years they're thinking
about the cha-ching the money and they
want to sign a big deal with Amazon to
have a permanent base basically at
Warner Brothers Studios where they would
produce two three movies a year for the
next 15 years and they want a very big
initial lump sum Amazon are not so Keen
to do that either
so they might just accelerate plans to
go It Alone Now this might be another
reason why getting an announcement for
Stargate RoboCop Etc is taking so damn
long MGM or the only IP MGM are doing a
lot of the work towards getting these
things made and we know that actually
the Stargate movie has been ordered that
Jennifer sulky has given Courtney
Valentini the permission to actually
start development work deadline wouldn't
be reporting it if it wasn't true so how
could Amazon actually get the studio
space it needs quickly enough to
actually start producing some of these
projects and why does that mean that
Stargate could be going home well Amazon
already has a very good working
partnership with something called the
Hackman group now the Hackman group 15
years ago wasn't really in the
entertainment business but now it's the
largest private owner of Studio space in
the world just like saying in the world
like that it just amuses me they are a
working partner with something called
the MBS group and they're the largest
owner of a prop studio in the world
they're the largest supply of lighting
and grip equipment Etc generally all
that stuff that you need to make
television and movies they're the big
player right now the hackerman group
owned 19 Studios they have 130 active
sound stages and they're currently
developing another 60. they're in seven
countries around the world and multiple
cities but why does Amazon have a good
worker relationship with these guys well
the hack group own Culver City Amazon
Studios headquarters is also at Culver
City
buildings that were constructed by the
hackerman group specifically for Amazon
at least two Amazon
so Amazon already have a very strong
working relationship with the Hackman
group perhaps that relationship is about
to go a lot further well the Hackman
group just announced that it's bought
the Vancouver film studios
this is 13 sound stages loads of
construction facilities so to build sets
Etc and lighting and production
equipment this is adding even more
capability to the hackerman group not
just actual land actual Studio space but
all of the facility equipment that goes
with it building props lighting
equipment grip equipment
etc etc etc so the Vancouver film
studios now that's an interesting
connection because where was Stargate
sg1 filmed again
Vancouver but not actually at the
Vancouver film studios they were
actually filmed at the bridge Studios
not that far away so
could there be a connection there well
yes the bridge Studios is currently
going through a massive development
project they're actually going to be
building 60 sound stages completely new
it really is a couple of billion quid
investment project and their partner in
that project MBS
the Hackman group's partner
so that again opens up a very
interesting possibility they are
currently constructing brand new Studios
could some of those Studios be swallowed
up by Stargate but some of the studios
are nearly done could Amazon move into
them and become a long-term partner with
the bridge Studios once again now why
would Amazon do that well for one it
would be quite a nice story and Amazon
like stories they would love to get that
press release out there that Stargate
sg1 is going home the fans will like it
don't get me wrong it's not the
massively important it's not massively
exciting but it would I don't know give
us a little bit of confidence even if
that confidence is kind of
based on nothing it'll be nice to give
the new Stargate project home now there
are financial reasons why actually
working in Vancouver is a good idea
really the same financial reasons that
took Stargate there in the first place
so this would be a nice story but more
importantly it would be a story that
actually has a financial reason for it
and that would interest Amazon so Amazon
might be about to go It Alone
particularly with the projects coming
out of MGM and Stargate could be about
to go home maybe possibly
Now what are my sources saying about
this I've actually been told to look at
this happening group a couple of times
before they're becoming a major player
in Hollywood very very quickly and they
have very big backers the Hackman group
is one of those companies that takes
funding from lots of different sources
and apparently a couple of those sources
are Amazon
so Amazon are invested in this company
already they're very very rapidly
becoming one of the big most important
players in Hollywood and really around
the world they already produce anything
up to 900 different Productions a year
Sony Warner Brothers Paramount Amazon
already everybody so yeah this is not
just a possibility
it's actually pretty likely the couple
of Studios that Amazon already have
including the world's largest virtual
studio studio 15 at Culver City it's
literally a sound stage with a massive
LED TV that they can use as a background
it apparently works were constructed and
are actually owned by the Hackman group
could Amazon be about to continue that
plan but on a much bigger scale
I think it's very possible
but what do you think and is it a good
idea to move away from these plans with
Warner Brothers and Sony I would argue
it's a very good idea because I actually
do think too many cooks do spoil the
broth and Warner Brothers and Sony would
have wanted at least some influence on
those projects do we want Warner
Brothers having influence on Stargate
we've already argued that actually
Warner Brothers were possibly trying to
push Bad Robot onto Stargate because of
the deal that they were hoping to strike
with Amazon hopefully that will finally
put that possibility to bed if Amazon
don't go with Warner Brothers but what
do you think go into the comments and
tell me if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you get to
see without the adverts as always please
stay safe guys and I will see you very
soon
[Music]